all really got on YouTube y'all saw that  they were taller guards that could be  just as fast as you you all saw that  there are six nine guards speed boosting  at the same speed as you and you still  decided to make a six foot one guard  with no defense and then you get on the  two's Court why would you go to the  two's court with no defense you get on  there and when the six nine is dangling  his nuts on your head you complain and  say the game has no defense this is what  I see when I see a 6-1 get on the court  this is what I see if you're gonna  complain about the room running at least  have a build with defense that can guard  it before you complain if you guard it  and they still remember on you then  maybe that's a problem but still stop  making two-way traffic homes them builds  are dead they're done they're done